rock paper scissors is an ancient game
of cunning and chance if only there was
a way to improve those chances turns out
there are a few key strategies research
has shown that there is a slight
preference for people to begin by
playing Rock so if we know that it gives
us an edge just play
Paper people who lose a hand tend to
change so there is a reasonable chance
that our opponent will change to
scissors or paper that gives us our
second Edge just Place scissors and we
should either win or Draw if we lost the
previous hand then our opponent might
reasonably expect us to switch to
something
else this gives us our final Edge
surprise them by sticking with our
previous Choice the less predictable you
are the better chance you have of
winning